little bit of an expanse update as
Amazon may actually be about to finally
release the TV rights back to
Alcon welcome to SRE your Sci-Fi TV and
M your
[Music]
channel so I've been talking about this
for nearly a year now that actually
Alcon were very keen to continue doing
something with the expanse at all the
things and TV Productions movie things
Etc that they own and Alcon do own the
IP to the expans that's the intellectual
property but Amazon owned the TV and
apparently the movie rights currently um
but Alcon that's basically their most
valuable asset that's the thing that
actually was reasonably successful for
them the game that was released recently
was very successful there's been a comic
book run etc etc so they've been very ke
for either Amazon to do something with
the expanse either a new series a return
whatever TV movie whatever or for them
to release the TV movie rights back to
Alcon now as your regular Sid trekers
would know if you've been following this
story that actually Alcon did build
something into the contract with Amazon
that if they didn't do something with
the IP for um I think I believe it was a
2-year period following the release of
the last series then um the rights
wouldt back to Alon and that would allow
them then to start talking to other
people if you again have followed the
story you'll know that Warner Brothers
apparently expressed an interest in that
um got 18 months ago or a year ago
something um that interest has waned
they're no longer going to be moving
forwards from that um but Apple
potentially still are now Ty Frank and
Daniel Abraham the original writer is
the sa Corey suum have been exploring
with Daren Shankar Aaron Shankar Maron
shanka Mr
shanka about creating a production
company that would allow them to
basically do the Penguin and a Parker
role because penguin a Parker have now
moved on to God of War and they will not
be involved in any new project that
alcom push forwards with so they've been
looking into creating a production
company that would allow them to then um
work with Alcon and produce some sort of
new TV series potentially for Apple well
the contract I spoke to a few months ago
actually that Alon were trying to get
those TV rights reverted back to
themselves early so at the moment it
would be like next summer or something
that the rights would revert Alcon would
really like though to start making a
little bit of money a bit sooner than
that if at all possible and seeing that
they've got potential customers lined up
for something with the expanse they'd
quite like to do that now if you do like
the video though don't forget to like
subscribe and hit the Bell notification
so you don't miss any future videos also
add a comment and a thumbs up it really
does help us with those pesky little
YouTube
algorithms now apparently um two or
three months ago they went to Amazon and
they basically said look can we have the
rights back you're not going to do
anything with it can we have the rights
back and Amazon actually said well we
don't know we're not going to do
anything with it we might do something
and that pushed Alcon back and actually
threw him through a loop pound because
they were like you've expressed no
interest up till now they apparently
Amazon did look into maybe doing a
couple of TV movies just after um the
last season ended um but they very
quickly apparently decided now they
couldn't they wouldn't do the final
books any sort of Justice and um they
very quickly put those um plans um in
you know they put a pin in those pans um
I've actually spoke to sources that
apparently they went as far as sort of
storyboarding out some ideas for three
TV movies um but they just basically
said look we can't do the books any sort
of Justice in a TV movie and um it just
wouldn't work so um or would be way too
expensive and um for the the you know
the the fan base of the expanse just too
much money so not worth
doing um so the current situation is
that that really threw alcom through a
loop I'm being told that since Christmas
that situation may have changed back and
actually Amazon may now be willing to
release them across so they would get
the rights back back to alcom where I'm
being told is that this would be a
straight up release they would not um
ask for any money from Alcon it would
just be a yeah okay you can have them
back the only thing holding anything up
now really is um the legal side of
actually releasing those contracts back
um so something would have to be written
up very simply just to state that yes um
the contracts don't void um as soon as
that is done Alcon will be free again to
explore options for something to do with
the expanse what would that be I've
always been told from day one that they
would not jump straight into a new
series that if Apple take this on they
want it to be something that's different
to what came before so they don't
necessarily want to do the next season
what they would rather do is sort of
like um some sort of spin-off explore
something else within the vast universe
that was created for the expans series
um there's
several big things that were happening
at the end of the last season that they
could explore further there is actually
quite a big gap between book six and
seven um of the expans series and it's
nearly 30 years 25 years or something
like that so the thinking for apple is
well that's a massive window that we can
explore please guys get to the comments
and tell me what um story arcs you think
would be most interesting the bonus for
that is as well that Apple could bring
in different cast if it needed to um I'm
sure they'll be exploring to try to get
some of the more popular cast members
back but um if they can't if those those
people have moved on to the projects or
whatever it would really allow Apple to
do something completely different then
could look in the future at maybe
looking at um the next and book in the
series I actually think this is just
fair by Amazon um they're looking at
Alcon a company they work very well with
they created a brilliant Sci-Fi series
with they've done other projects with in
the past um Alcon of basically look on
look we need to start generating some
income from this IP please just let us
do that and even though Amazon may have
had a stop and a pause and think like
well actually do we want to do something
with this they've then had a meeting and
decided no no actually we don't so I
think this is just Amazon being very
reasonable now let's just see that once
Alcon gets this IP back and they
actually get the TV and movie rides back
can they strike a deal with somebody
like apple to bring back one of the most
realistic sci-fi shows ever made a
Sci-Fi show that I actually think would
fit perfectly on Apple it just it just
screams the sort of project that apple
have done in the past and the sort of
thing they've done very well you look at
something like the foundation whether
you like it or love it imagine that with
you know the the the expanse writers and
everything in the expanse universe that
sort of style that sort of feel to it I
think it just screams that that would be
perfect but guys get into the comments
and tell me what you think is this a
deal that sounds right to you is it
something that you'd be excited to have
return or actually the expans was great
but we've moved on tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go over to
patreon.com citre where most of our new
videos do appear first and you get to
see them without the adverts you lucky
bunnies also go to um s.co which is our
dedicated website and we Tred to do
articles based on a lot of our videos
and we try to write a bit more
information if you to digest go check it
out as always please stay safe and I'll
see you next
time
[Music]